[Music]
foreign
you're watching the Press preview a
first look at what is on the front pages
as they arrive well it's time to see
what is making the headlines that is
with the Daily Mirror columnist Susie
Boniface and the writer Benedict uh
Spencer load to both of you they'll be
with us from now until just before
midnight so let's take a look at what is
on some of those front pages
well the eye says that new figures
showing the UK heading for two years of
recession have prompted Rishi sunak to
delay his plan to grow the economy
meanwhile the telegraph carries warnings
that expected public sector strikes in
the coming months could lead to an
increase in crime
and the express hears that officials
from the UK could be posted to France in
an effort to curb migrant Crossings in
the channel
and the times understands plans are
being drawn up which would ban care
homes from refusing residents the
opportunity to see visitors
and the financial times reports on the
collapse of the cryptocurrency firm FTX
and the guardian has a story about the
alleged behaviors of cabinet minister
Dominic Raab he denies any wrongdoing
and the star offers a response from the
Britain's Got Talent contestant about
whom Judge David walliams could be heard
making derogatory sexual remarks in
off-air footage
and the male criticizes a senior police
officer for being too politically
correct because he raised awareness of
what it's like for women to experience
the menopause
and The Mirror Has the latest from I'm a
celebrity and former Health secretary
Matt Hancock's interactions with his
fellow contestants
and according to the sun ITV have been
condemned for allowing Mr Hancock to eat
a certain part of a camel's Anatomy
and a reminder that by scanning the QR
code you'll see on screen during the
program you can check out the front
pages of tomorrow's papers while you
watch us talking about them well we're
joined uh tonight by Susie Boniface and
Benedict Spence hello to both of you
rock and roll Friday night talking about
the papers
um I was just reading the headlines
there you can see that they run the
gamuts didn't they um pretty pretty wide
range of things for us to talk about
tonight let's kick off though with the
front page of the eye prime minister
delays growth plan as UK heads for
recession it was all about growth only
about six weeks ago wasn't it Susie
yeah and this is actually this was one
of the things that he wanted to do you
know then there was talk here he's now
he had planned to cut tax on things like
business investments in capital projects
uh but that announcement was expected
quite soon but he's just not going to be
able to do that the circle that Rishi
sunak Casta Square in the public
finances uh is simply not allowing him
to do the things that uh were expected
and that were needed and there's other
bits of papers we don't get to talk
about later on but um that there's
actually some concern that while Rishi
sunak is trying to steady the ship as it
were and uh you know adopt the Orthodoxy
and improve confidence in Britain PLC
there is some concerns that he's going
to be over correcting and perhaps
cutting too many things and at the wrong
way and a bit too soon so that the slump
we're all going to go and experience in
the next few years is going to be far
far worse than it needs to be and of
course the the figures that came out
today showing that Britain is the only
G7 country that's it's heading into
recession does rather back up the fact
that Britain's economy for some bizarre
reason has got something strange going
on in it that isn't affecting every
other developed economy yeah well what
could that be I think I wonder um that
those figures also show that we are the
only economy Benedict in the G7 that's
got a smaller economy uh than before
covid
um suggests to me that really growth it
shouldn't be forgotten about it's what's
needed
yes it's a story of Tory economic Hokey
Cokey we had Liz truss who weren't a
little too hard for growth and now we've
got Rishi sunak who's going a little too
far uh in the other direction and they
just can't seem to quite get it right
and I mean I think that this does need
to be born in mind first and foremost is
that this is I think going to be a sign
that the Civil Strife within the Tory
party isn't going to go away in much the
same way that there was a lot of
backlash against this trust perhaps
it'll be a little quieter a little more
study but nonetheless there's going to
be a lot of opposition from within uh
the back benches to uh Rishi sunak and
you know this is going to mean that you
know we've talked to a great length
about how the adults are back in charge
back in the room and that we're now back
to steady government I don't think we
are at all I think we're going to see a
little bit more
um a little bit more backstabbing as we
go forward and yeah it wouldn't be the
Tory party if there wasn't that going on
but yeah more broadly yes it must be
very concerning for a great many people
you know coming off the back of uh a lot
of people will say coming off the back
of the lockdowns and the crevice but
it's not just that it is decades of
underperforming of a failure actually to
fix roofs while suns are shining to
prioritize things like growth because
actually that's the time when you need
to be looking to these things it's not
in the aftermath of a series of massive
shots to the economic system it's when
things are going well and you know it
posts 2008 uh uh with uh George Osborne
and the Coalition and austerity Britain
lost wasted a decade basically a
potential growth which other members of
the developed world didn't and it does
now look as if we are going to go back
down that route again you have to have
Prudence but really we should have
learned from the last 10 years of
experience ultimately if you don't allow
people to grow they can't fund
themselves they can't pay the taxes they
can't afford the public services and
you'd end up in a cycle of regression
yeah causing consternation the eye also
points out amongst the business
Community uh amongst whom a relationship
with the conservative government hasn't
always been what it should be has it uh
Susie let's let's also talk about other
people which may have some concerns
about what may come out of this Autumn
statement next week this is in the times
this is the top rate taxpayers
Susie yeah there's some suggestion that
maybe about a quarter of a minute what's
happening at the moment let's just go
back a little bit what's happening at
the moment is that there are treasury
briefings going out fairly consistently
to journalists about all different mad
things they might do and they're flying
lots of kites to see what goes well and
what doesn't go well and one of the
suggestions here is that a quarter of a
million people could be made to pay the
Top bait of tax and these are people who
are earning big figures okay so these
are people on on Six Figure salaries
um and that they're going to be perhaps
introduced uh bring them into a higher
tax Band or maybe even there was some
suggestion I saw a couple of days ago
about bringing back the 50p tax rate
which Gordon Brown had now whether or
not this is happening who knows it's one
of those things where there's lots of
journalists trying to find stuff out and
you hear things you go gosh that's good
um but you can't substantiate it because
there is no way to substantiate whether
option A or option b is definitely
happening because neither option A or B
has actually been decided yet it's all
still very much up in the air and so the
journalists saying we've heard something
we've heard something but it's it's all
built on on rather shifting sound and
that's not the journalist's fault it's
kind of the fault the fact that the
government can't really decide and
they're so lacking in their own
confidence of their own economic ideas
and ideals that they're literally having
to float it in the pages of the
telegraph of the times or the mail every
day to see if it would work or not yeah
they know yeah well I should apologize
to our viewers to having to look at
those uh rather unedifying photographs
of the former Health secretary there on
uh in the times uh treating himself to
what looks like a rather unappetizing
hors d'oeuvre let's move on shall we to
the telegraph Benedict uh another day it
almost feels like another day another
strike gets announced more industrial
action uh this is the Met warning about
what the knock-on effects of that will
be
yeah I was just gonna say actually
what's more what's more painful for two
for 250 000 workers is it the fact that
they're gonna have to pay more tax or is
it being subjected to Matt Hancock on
your television every evening yeah it's
a pretty difficult one to turn at least
he's not dancing
I mean it's early in the series who
knows what could happen anything is on
the table
um
what have I done I've just I've just
sort of I should have Dreadful sort of
mental image unto everybody yeah you've
taken us also into a cold
I have what were we talking about sorry
before Matt Hancock talk about the Met
warning about industrial activities
yeah
um Honestly though this is um
this is of course the other thing that
goes on doesn't it when you have sort of
an economic crisis is that you have uh
industrial action you have stripes from
public sector workers who are being left
behind of course we've been talking a
great deal throughout the last week
about the nurses strikes and uh now
we're you know moving on to the Met
police who are suggesting that
um you know a time that is spent uh uh
on on Healthcare it is going to It's
Gonna it's gonna make things very
difficult it's going to stretch demand
uh on public services it's going to
distract the police from doing their job
because they're going to have to be sort
of you know stepping in to assist
um and you're just generally speaking
I'm terribly sorry there is a cat that
is trying to climb up my leg and it's
absolutely just
oh it's all going so well isn't it
I'm terrible I'm terrified tonight it's
Friday night the cat doesn't know you're
live on Sky News to be fair to your cat
it doesn't it doesn't but it will know
soon I think it's probably it's a good
place to go to the break and uh you can
do whatever you need to do to modify
your cat in the meantime sorry plenty to
talk about uh after the break do stay
with us coming up Susie's going to be
telling us more about her campaign with
the mirror to get Justice for Cold War
veterans who've had their health
severely damaged by exposure to nuclear
materials you can join us after the
break for a discussion about that
[Music]
foreign
you're watching the Press preview with
me again Susie Boniface and Benedict
Spence perhaps without your cat this
time uh Benedict Susie let's come to you
um in the mirror this is of course been
part of your campaign for recognition
for nuclear veterans
yeah so uh in today's paper which is I
suppose on yesterday's press preview now
we ran a front page story and four pages
inside detailing the results of a
six-month investigation which
established that the ministry of Defense
had had blood and urine samples of those
men who served at nuclear tests back in
the 1950s and 1960s and that they had
told Parliament these these things
didn't exist uh that they had told
veterans that the records didn't exist
and then when they did know the records
existed they were withholding them and
refusing to provide them to Veterans and
we run a story basically saying that um
these could potentially be a criminal
offense we showed this evidence some of
it to Boris Johnson when we met him in
June he agreed then as prime minister
that it could potentially be a criminal
offense labor are calling for a public
inquiry there's going to be moves afoot
in Parliament about it next week and now
what's happened is that when he was
running for office uh back in August
Rishi sunax said he would support a
medal for these veterans but also most
importantly he he said he would support
a criminal investigation to see if
service at the tests to get Britain its
nuclear deterrence had constituted a
crime against the test veterans so when
we had this story I went to number 10
and I said hey guys you'll never guess
what I think we've got some evidence
that there may be some crimes does Rishi
stand by the thing he said in August and
I went to them maybe three times during
the course of the day maybe four can I
remember now and in the end they refused
to make any comment whatsoever they just
put out one standard comment from the
government which is it's completely
untrue not addressing any of our detail
not talking about any of the evidence
complete utterly unable to bat away any
of it just going uh no nothing yeah and
particularly uncomfortable no today
isn't it on Armistice Day
exactly it's Armistice Day Rishi as
everyone did observe two minute silence
at 11AM but unfortunately he's also
maintaining the 70-year silence these
veterans and their families have had to
endure and despite going to him again
today and saying look please will you
have another opportunity you've seen our
evidence will you still support a
criminal investigation of these veterans
yeah there's silence there's not even no
there's not even I'll think about it
silence Benedict a very quick word from
you about a big blow up in the crypto
world
oh well this is I mean this is a
staggering story what's the most money
you've ever lost in one day I bet you've
not lost 32 billion uh that's just
disappeared but that's what's happened
to FTX it's one of the the crypto
sphere's largest exchanges or it was it
now no longer exists after the CEO of a
rival firm uh called binance uh
basically called it out that it couldn't
continue to operate uh within a day it
had basically admitted fdx's uh founder
Sam bankman Freud had basically admitted
that it couldn't function anymore and
just like that Puff the money was gone
the situation has collapsed it's caused
a huge run in the crypto sphere Bitcoin
down ethereum down all sorts of things
going off and I mean why this is
actually this might sound a bit of a
niche story but actually Sam bankman
fried the founder of FDX
railroads in apologies to jump in there
but I'm gonna have to cut you off
because we're out of time so we're gonna
have to leave it on that cliff hang out
there